This is Special Issues,
Suicide, and
Violent Patients.
I'm Dr. Jeffrey Goldberg.
I'm going to start
out with a case that
appeared in Frontiers
of Psychiatry in
September 2023. This
is a case report of an
elderly single retired
school principal
with obsessive compulsive
personality traits
who developed depression
with psychotic
symptoms after being
isolated following
quarantining during
the COVID-19 pandemic.
The social isolation
led to feelings
of loneliness
and hopelessness.
The patient's
depressive symptoms
worsened after he
developed physical
illnesses, such as
eye floaters, and
that affected his
daily activities.
This caused him to
have suicidal ideation
to the extent that
he attempted suicide
by ingesting 90
milliliters of pesticide.
Two weeks prior to the
attempt, he updated
his will and asked
his friend to keep it.
So this case has
several risk factors in
it for suicide, and
I wonder if you can
identify them, and
perhaps you will be
able, better to be
able, after this
lecture, how can suicide
be prevented? What
can you do as doctors
and future doctors
to prevent suicide
in your patients?
What can we do
and how well do
we do in
predicting suicide?
That'll be a
main thrust of
what we're going
to talk about.
And your objectives and
everything is laid
out in the CPG.
you have some
materials and links
to the Columbia
Suicide Rating Scale
and Preventing
Suicide and Statistics
and Facts put
out by the CDC.
Well,
if you didn't
know it before,
suicide is the
11th leading cause
of death in the
United States.
and at one time
or another it was
higher on the list but
it was bumped off by
COVID-19 deaths
the most recent
statistics go to 2022
where close to 50
,000 Americans died by
suicide suicide that is
uh on average uh close
to 132 suicides a day
uh virtually one every
11 or 12 minutes um
give or take men dying
by suicide almost four
times more than women
And the age of dust
rate in 2022 in the
United States is 14.21
suicides per 100,000
individuals. um and say
in uh in 85 year old
and up uh that goes uh
up to um around 20 21
uh per hundred thousand
maybe um a little
more and if you look
at individuals who are
over 55 as a group that
It goes even higher,
that adjusted
rate of suicide.
In the United
States, firearms
account for over
50% of all suicide
deaths, and white
males account
for nearly 70% of
deaths in 2022.
I refer you to
the American
Foundation for Suicide.
and the AFSP
.org, American
Foundation for
Suicide Prevention,
where they lay out nicely
all these statistics.
Take a look.
What do I want to
say about suicide?
Well, it's a
complex phenomenon.
And we, even despite
our screening
tools, our
understanding of the
risk factors, we
still fall short
in predicting and
preventing it.
Again, greater than
50% of suicides are
with firearms. Probably
the single best
thing that we could
do to prevent suicide
is to educate about
safe firearm storage,
limit access to high
-risk individuals for
firearms, and in terms
of the storage, you
know, keeping bullets and
the firearm separated.
Suicide sometimes can
be very impulsive,
and the firearm, in
terms of the fatality,
sometimes there's no
coming back from that.
One thing that on
this data chart
that they put out
is now we have a
three-digit number
for suicide, if not
nationwide, almost
nationwide, 988.
It handles millions
of hotline calls
for people that are in
crisis and suicidal.
So you're not,
you know, fumbling
for a 1-800 number.
If you're feeling not
safe in crisis,
having thoughts of
suicide, pick up the
phone and dial 988.
We have some data that
Birkin Foundation for
Suicide puts out. It
shows in New York a
suicide rate of 8.47
per 100,000, and for our
Arkansas folks, that
rate goes up to 18.03
per 100,000. And you
can see the distribution
across the United States
in terms of rates.
Even looking at Alaska
of a rate of 27.13.
Now, some of these
rates may coincide
with easy access
to firearms, may
coincide with higher
rates of alcohol
***** and depression
and might coincide
with access to
care and help for
depression and mental
health conditions.
This is a chart that
the CDC puts out
about the leading
causes of death.
And you'll see
in the green,
it is the second
leading cause
of death in 10
to 14 year olds
third in 15 to
24 year olds
and second in 25
to 34 year olds
then dropping down
the list to number 6 in
45 to 54 and then 9th in
55- to 64-year-olds.
Note well,
unintentional injuries
lead the cause of death
in the under 44,
you know, in the 1
- to 44-year-old
group and in the 45
and all ages,
the third leading
cause of death. Some of
these unintentional
injuries are no doubt
suicide and note that
in some instances
suicide you know
homicide and
suicide are kind
of neck and neck
you could go to american
foundation and look
up any state i thought
we'd pull it up
for arkansas it's the
11th leading cause of
death in arkansas um
and they note that 66
percent of communities
don't have enough
mental health providers
to serve the residents
which is a key factor
and that over three
times as many people
died by suicide than
in alcohol and related
motor of vehicles
and 56 percent were
firearm deaths 56 percent
of all firearm deaths
were suicides and
63 percent of all
suicides were by firearms
we have a similar
uh scope for new
york in terms of
uh it's the uh
see just one second okay
yeah It's the 49th in
terms of state rank.
Less than half of
the communities don't
have enough mental
health services.
Four times as
many people died
by suicide than
alcohol deaths.
Only 26% of all suicides
were from firearms.
41% of the deaths of
firearms were suicides.
So who is the
suicidal patient then?
It's a white male,
usually older, or
we saw that in that
age, the younger
age group, they
might be divorced,
never married or
widowed and unemployed.
That is a common
demographic.
They've
had a previous
suicide attempt.
That is a risk factor.
That's probably the most
significant risk factor,
a robust risk
factor, that they've
had a previous
suicide attempt with
a serious intent,
lethal means.
There might be a
family history of
suicide. They might
themselves be the
victim of physical
or ****** *****.
Over 90% of
patients who are
suicidal or committed
suicide, you
know, had a
psychiatric disorder.
Might have concurrent use
of alcohol or
illicit drugs.
And the key point is
they might have had
a recent psychiatric
hospitalization.
That first 30 days
after hospitalization
is a key period
where we see
increased suicide
attempts and suicide.
Environmentally,
they're socially
isolated. They have
access to guns.
They might have
had a recent loss.
And there's a
social acceptance
that suicide is a
possible solution.
a way out. It might
be accepted in their
culture or the family
as a way of avoiding
humiliating and
embarrassment.
They might have had
a severe medical
illness, especially
with loss of
functioning or
intractable pain.
So I want to go back
to the case because
We had someone who
was isolating during
COVID-19, already
feeling lonely and
depressed and hopeless,
and then symptoms
worsened after he
developed physical
illnesses, his
vision was affected,
he couldn't function
because of poor
vision, let's say,
and eye floaters.
uh and uh so that
loss of functioning
uh or intractable
pain is a key factor
behaviorally well
you could see someone
preparing for death
making a will again
right consistent with
our our patient two
weeks prior to his
attempt he updated
his will and they ask
a friend to keep it.
So if they've had
a well-developed,
detailed plan,
if they made
statements to
harm themselves
with intent to afflict
harm, they have poor
impulse control or
antisocial in some way.
These are all possible
characteristics.
So we take all threats,
gestures, attempts
seriously.
we're aware of
the possibility
and we try and
establish a rapport
before honing in on
the issue of suicide
it's
hard to just go up to
the patient and ask
them are you planning
to kill yourself
they may not tell you
you have to try
and establish trust
and a rapport
before doing that.
You'll do a mental
status exam.
You'll ask, certainly
at some point,
about suicidal
thoughts, ideas, wishes,
motives,
and with the
idea that you're
not trying to judge them.
So after establishing
the rapport,
you want to know, and
a person might say,
you know, I'm thinking,
I was thinking about
suicide, that I feel
there's no way out.
And you'll say, well,
do you have a plan?
What were you thinking?
Do they have lethal
means available?
Do they have a
firearm, for instance?
And is there a chance?
Are they trying, really?
Are they ambivalent
about it? Are they
trying to be rescued?
I always like to
check for, do they
have futuristic
thinking? Are there
any realistic plans
for the future?
Why now? What's
happened now?
What's happened recently?
What was the precipitant?
What was the loss?
And again,
reassuring the person
that you're not
judging them, that
you're going to
maintain that
confidentiality or privacy
to the extent that
it's possible.
But in almost all
circumstances,
you're going to
want to be able
to talk to friends
or relatives,
and you want
to be able to
reassure the
person that you're
doing that in
a discreet way.
and of course
you're always
going to review
for risk factors
comorbid depression
alcoholism
psychosis medical
illness prior attempts
so here is the columbia
suicide severity
rating scale and
it's not a scale
in the sense that
you quantify it
that you you add it
all up rather after
establishing rapport
with patients
you screen for suicide
and you say you
know have you ever
wished you were
dead or wish you
could go to sleep and
not wake up in the
past month have you
had any thoughts
of killing yourself
and then if yes
to question two
you ask questions
three four five and six
if no to two you go
directly to six which
basically you're supposed
to ask all the time
like in your lifetime
have you ever done
anything to or prepared
to do anything to
end your life and if
yes ask how long ago
did you do any of these
so this is actually
an evidence based
tool that's used in
primary care and in
behavioral health it's used
everywhere in the
in the health care
environment so it turns
out that people who
die by suicide are
actually more likely to
have seen a primary
care physician in the
previous month before
uh their uh suicide
attempt right they've
seen a primary care
physician in the previous
month before their
death than any other
health care provider.
I mean, that is just
a staggering finding
to me that people
who die by suicide
are more likely to
have seen a primary
care provider in the
previous month before
their death than any
other health care
provider. What does
it mean? It means
that a visit to the
primary care provider
may be the only chance
to assess needed
care, right? That
is the opportunity.
And unless you're
going to do the
screening using an
evidence-based tool,
you're not going to
discover who potentially
is suicidal and
then intervene.
The other thing we
see, and when you do
intervene, the other
thing we see in primary
care sometimes is that
with antidepressant
treatment, it's either
too short or it's
not maximized. So
primary care doctors are
now encompassing
and learning about
antidepressant treatment
as part of primary care.
And at the same
time, also screening
and addressing
alcohol disorders that
are under-detected
and under-treated.
One thing, though,
that you can do in
primary care and
elsewhere is develop this
patient safety plan.
That is a key element
in terms of suicide
prevention, where
the patient, with the
patient, they write
out what are the
recognized warning signs?
What are the personal
warning signs
that might put them
in a suicidal episode?
What internal coping
strategies do they have?
What are, who are
social contacts
that can offer support or
distraction from
suicidal thought?
And number four, who
are the family members
and friends to help
resolve a crisis?
And then number five,
who are the professions
and agencies and
professional people who
can be called to help?
And then number six,
what could be done to
make the environment
safe? Like, you know,
I'm thinking about
suicide, I have a gun,
maybe give the gun
to someone else, take
away the bullets. What
can you do to keep
the environment safe?
So this safety
plan, and of course,
the one thing
at the bottom,
the one thing that
is most important
to me and worth
living for is,
and to put that on to
try and put something
empowering and and
positive as part
of the safety plan
this is something that
patients can turn to
when they start to
feel suicidal and
it's been shown to be
effective in helping
reduce the suicidal
crisis it's even
available you know on
as an app on cell phone.
And as a reminder,
it's only a tool and
it's only one part
of a comprehensive
suicide care plan.
Other mnemonics
and reminders,
the SAD persona scale,
the risk factors,
right, male,
very young or very
old, accompanying
depression, the
fact that they had a
previous attempt,
that they're abusing
alcohol, R, that
they're psychotic,
S, that they have
no social supports,
O, they have a plan, N,
recently widowed,
divorced, or never
married, or no
partner, no spouse,
A, availability of
lethal means, and S,
for sickness, that
they have some serious
medical condition
or intractable
illness, maybe intractable
COPD or brittle
diabetes or some
disfigurement or some
chronic impairment
that accompanies all
this. And all these
factors together
put a person at higher
risk for suicide.
another mnemonic is
this no hope scale where
the person might
have no framework for
meaning for living
right they don't there's
no motivation or
reason for them to live
they feel that way
something has changed in
their clinical condition
um maybe they were
given a terminal
diagnosis or maybe as
part of this scenario,
they're in a hostile
interpersonal environment
where there's a
recent divorce or
they're not getting along
with family members
or they've just been
discharged from the
hospital or inpatient
psychiatry recently, or
they have a predisposing
impulsivity uh or
aggressiveness or risk
-taking and more most
importantly that they
they feel hopeless
that they feel that
there's a good reason
for dying that people
would be better off
without them and that
they may be a burden
to others so that that
excuse in and of itself
could push a person
over the limit, the
no hope scale, no H
-O-P-E, hostile, out,
predisposing excuses.
How do we intervene
in terms of, besides
psychotherapy, the
idea that there
are certain
medications, such as
clozapine, which is
FDA-approved to reduce
risk of suicide
and schizophrenia.
Lithium showed a
five-fold decrease
in bipolar
disorder when taken
for patients who
are suicidal,
and the patients that
have bipolar disorder.
Antidepressants, uh
some of them have a
black box warning ssr
eyes left out the i
there but it's ssr eyes
uh they may uh have
a warning because they
they might increase
the suicide risk in
children adolescents
but it's been shown
when we didn't use
them and when we stayed
away from them we
showed actually
increase the suicide and
suicidal behavior so the
idea is use but monitor,
monitor for
suicidality, monitor for
restlessness, and
monitor for side effects.
And then finally,
we're seeing the
use of ketamine in
refractory major
depression.
Ketamine, which is a
glutamate, NMDA
receptor antagonist.
and it's shown that IV
infusions have an anti
-suicidal effect
that's outside of the
antidepressant effect
that ketamine might have.
Now, these IV
infusions are not FDA
approved, but what
is approved now
with ketamine is the
use of an enantamark
of ketamine
called esketamine.
and it has a specific
FDA indication
for suicidality
and it now has an
approved FDA approval
given intranasally.
There is a dissociation
effect that
happens with the use
of the intranasal
preparation and that's
why patients have to
be monitored for a
period after its use.
What do we do?
That's violence to
yourself, suicide.
But what do we do in
terms of violence
to others? How do we
assess dangerousness
in psychiatry?
To that regard, we
look at does the
individual threaten
****** harm or are they
looking to do harm
to property, right?
are they threatening
to kill someone or
is it just to beat up
or not that that is
any less concerning
or assault somebody
many people make all
kinds of threats but
how likely is it
that the fear of harm
will occur that has
to go into assessing
dangerousness and then
when will it happen
how imminent is
it and then how
frequently will the
action occur so when
assessing someone
for dangerous and
dangerous to self or
others again that's
the standard for
a civil commitment
we have to look into
all these areas the
nature of the harm
the magnitude the
probability the imminence
and the frequency
uh and then we get
into this whole area
of confidentiality uh
if someone is dangerous
what you know what
do we do uh in
terms of uh confidentiality
because we have
uh what we call the
clinician's obligation
to keep information
learned in the
relationship unavailable
to third parties,
and it's essential to
psychiatric treatment,
because patients
are not going to
disclose or tell us
anything about their deepest
thoughts or fears
or actions if they
know that what they're
going to discuss
is going to be released
to third parties.
so sometimes there
are exceptions to
confidentiality right
sometimes the patient
requests release of
information uh and we're
going to get into when
there's an identified
victim we have a
duty to protect uh
that victim we'll
we'll talk about uh
exceptions to
confidentiality in terms
of certain emergency
situations. Sometimes
there are
mandatory reporting
statutes, especially
like for child *****.
Sometimes on the
subpoena or court-ordered
evaluations, we would
reach confidentiality.
And sometimes the
patient initiates their
own litigation in some
matter. And we, as part
of that, are asked to
disclose information
that would otherwise
remain confidential.
When patients are on
the inpatient unit,
staff, the nursing
personnel, consultants,
and the patient,
they're all on one team,
and information is
freely shared with one
another. But there
is this circle of
confidentiality, And
patients have the right to
keep their inpatient
hospitalization separate
from the police,
from the outside,
therapists, the previous
therapists, from the
family, from the lawyer,
if they request it.
but within and
among the treatment
team information
has to be shared
and flow freely
between the staff
and the different
nursing and
support personnel
to keep the patient
safe and to
treat the patient
so when we have to
breach a confidentiality
uh it's important to
notify the patient that
you're doing this and
to and to document
the rationale for
action that's the most
important bullet on the
slide you you want to be
able to explain what
your reasoning is what
was compelling that
you had to breach
confidentiality and what
purpose does it serve.
So sometimes in an
emergency situation,
especially when the
individual is
incapacitated
or not available,
you are able to use
your professional
judgment to disclose
information if it's
in the best interest
of the individual.
And this actually is in
the HIPAA privacy rule.
In other words,
if a patient
lacks capacity to agree
or object to
the sharing of
personal health
information,
including for
psychiatric reasons,
and you believe that
it's an emergency
and you document
its emergency,
it's up to you the
clinician to decide
whether to disclose
personal health
information to a
personal contact
you know you may
need information from
someone someone
comes into the er
and and you and they're
saying they don't
want you to talk to any
relatives or personal
contacts etc and
they're not disclosing
information about them
or what medication
they're taking or
anything But you have a
number, and in order
to treat them, and in
order to render them
safe and those around
them safe, you might
go ahead and breach
confidentiality and
contact and disclose
personal information
to a personal contact.
Now, of no listening
to a personal contact,
express their
concerns about a
patient's mental illness
doesn't constitute
a use or a use
of disclosure.
So you could listen
and personal contacts
could give you
information, express
their concerns,
and that's not a
breach of confidentiality.
potentiality.
So if it's necessary
to prevent or lessen
a serious or imminent
threat to a person
or a public, and you
believe a disclosure
is made to someone
they believe can
prevent or lessen the
threat, that is an
exception. And that applies
to acute psychiatric
decompensation if
good faith clinical
judgment supports
it he is documented
now the tarasoff
case is an important
case in terms of
confidentiality and trying
to understand
where we are now in
terms of the requirement
for mental health
professionals to
reach it and to notify
law enforcement and
potential victims.
So in 1976,
Tarasov versus
the Regents of the
University of California,
it's a landmark
decision in U.S.
mental health law.
It established a
therapist's duty to warn,
but not only to warn,
to protect potential
victims if a patient
poses a threat of
violence. So the one
key factor is that the
victim, potential
victim, has to be
identified. It just
can't be a global threat.
It has to be a specific
identified victim.
so uh the case
involved uh a graduate
student at uc berkeley
he told his therapist
at the counseling
center he wanted to
kill tatiana tarasov
a fellow student with
whom he had become
obsessed actually the
therapist of uh of
the graduate student
notified the campus
belief police who
briefly detained the
graduate student, but
released him after
he appeared rational.
No one warned
Tarasov or her family
about this. A year
later, he carried
out his threat,
killing Tarasov.
So the California
Supreme Court ruled
that a mental health
professional has
a duty to warn, and
then in the second
hearing of the case
later to protect a
patient when a patient
possesses, when
a patient poses a
foreseeable danger.
This decision
expanded therapist
liability and reshaped
confidentiality
standards in mental
health care across
the country. And so
many states adopted
a duty to warn or
duty to protect.
Some it's in
their case law.
Some of it's in
specific regulations.
So it varies state
to state, but
it's generally
accepted that,
and certainly in New
York, that there's
a duty to protect when
there's an identified
victim being threatened
by a patient.
Now, psychiatrists
and mental
health professionals
can't address
all violence in
society, race.
We can't address
the proliferation
of firearms or the
use of firearms.
You know, there's
aspects about violence
in society that go
beyond the specialty
of psychiatry and
medicine in general.
But there are
psychiatric disorders
where one can see
increased aggression
and violence.
Patients with
schizophrenia, with
poor impulse control,
might have command
auditory hallucinations
to hurt themselves
or people.
Patients with
enigmatic episode might
suddenly become violent
when they are given
limit setting or
things are taken away
from them. The borderline
personality patient
that can't tolerate
being abandoned,
look at the famous,
from movies, the famous
Glenn Close character
in Fatal Attraction,
at the thought of
being abandoned
by the Michael Douglas
character, becomes
violent as a way to
deal with her anger.
losing her love object
and the personality
disorders that
have impulsivity
and high risk taking
and certainly patients
with anti social
personality disorder
that have no guilt about
hurting or stealing
or attacking others
in terms of
organically induced
aggression or aggression
due to medical
causes, there's an
extensive list that
goes into different
CNS conditions,
central nervous system
conditions, metabolic
disorders, alcohol
intoxication,
steroids, droid range,
antidepressants can
be very activating,
amphetamines, and
*******, the aggression
associated with
asthmatic excitement
in response to
amphetamines and *******,
anticholinergic
effects of medication,
and the whole
anticholinergic syndrome,
where one could be mad as
a hat or red as a beet.
Antipsychotics,
especially ones that
lead to akathisia,
where a patient
becomes so restless
that cancer is still
that they become
so hyperactive that
they start *******
into other people.
Now, on an inpatient
unit, especially,
and the outpatient
settings, we're
concerned always
about younger
clinicians and
experienced clinicians.
The inpatient and
ER is certainly
an area where people are
more vulnerable
to aggression.
Certainly nursing is
our profession that's
out front and has
high degree of face-to
-face contact and more
time with patients. um
if you're a clinician
that is in any way
provocative or aggressive
in your actions uh
it might might set off
patients when you set
a limit for a patient
that also might be
uh something that you
need to be aware of and
of course psychotic
disorder we mentioned
the patient with
schizophrenia or psychotic
disorder that has a
command hallucination
or the person
that is fixated or
has a persecutory
delusion that
you're after them
or being harmed and
they want to
defend themselves.
So dealing with
the acute patient,
we want to think
about safety first.
Where's the interview?
Am I in an isolated area?
Do I have a
means of escape?
Do people know
that I'm there?
Is the patient
blocking the door?
We want to talk to with
how we talk to patients.
We'll get into
that is important.
Do we have some
training in
terms of
physical defense?
And, you know, are
we coming in in
a highly charged
emotional state?
So it's important
to recognize the
warning signs of
aggression and violence.
have staff that
are trained,
have adequate staff,
and have staff
recognize and
acknowledge
their feelings.
Are people with mental
illness less likely
to be violent than the
general population?
Well, in general, people
with mental illness
are more likely to
be victimized by
violence and
aggression than commit.
and many violent
acts never really
reached the
attention of the
police because the
charges are not
brought because
the person is ill
and about one third
of all psychiatric
admissions are
preceded by violence
so some truth to
that but more likely
patients with mental
illness are going
to be victimized
than perpetrators
the prototypical
demographic is a young male
poorly educated no
support network they
might have a psychotic
disorder they might
have tbi they might have
a personality disorder
they might be
intoxicated they've had a
past history of violence
and early victimization
themselves and
psychologically low
frustration tolerance
right uh low self-esteem
low tolerance for
interpersonal closeness
uh low tolerance
for criticism and
externalization
everything you know
whatever's going
on it's my it's it's
your fault um it's
the police's fault uh
it's someone else's
that they don't have
any responsibility or
take any responsibility
for their situation.
Just like with any other
condition, we
take a history.
Do you have thoughts
of harming someone?
Are there plans?
What would make you act?
Is there concurrent
alcohol use?
Is there any evidence
of being reckless,
aggression or aggressive
uh any recent uh
provocations quarrels
um previous any previous
violence again like
suicide previous suicide
attempt high risk previous
violence high risk
for current violence
interesting question
um what made you stop
what why didn't you act
at that time if a plan
wasn't carried out?
Do they have an
arrest record?
Have they been in prison?
Are they themselves
have been
the victim of
violence? Is there
a family history
of violence?
And again,
asking and
looking for a
history of head
trauma, psychosis,
seizures,
encephalitis,
et cetera.
and in childhood
um whether they
themselves were
victimized with parental
brutality how much
was violence normative
in the family and
then the culture
and did they have
this triad of fire
setting bedwetting and
cruelty to animals so
how do you approach a
potentially aggressive
violent patient
uh you want to be
aware of your body
posture your voice uh
may still be understood
uh by the patients
even though they
may be psychotic so
they may not be able to
process or understand
your words so um
but they're able to
certainly you know,
see you, right? So
your posture is very
important. You want
to allow more physical
space than usual.
A buffer zone is
four times larger,
so keep that space
in the, you know,
away from the
violent patient.
Never approach
patients from behind.
Don't face them
directly. It could be
perceived as confrontational
um again be aware
of where the exits are
don't block the door
or the exit and these
these slides are really
all part of a greater
training but i put
them in there for
informational purposes
the idea that you're
not going to run uh
words right it's you
sort of do a sideways
sidestep, sort of an
electric, I call it an
electric slide away from
the patient by moving
the nearest foot
from behind the other
and then moving the
other front foot across.
Ideally, you and
the patient should
be equidistant
from the door so
the patient won't
feel cornered.
Important point there.
um you keep your
awareness about your
eye contact be neutral
hands uh midline
to the body not
folding them or at
your waist which is
comfort confrontational
be aware of the
striking range at
least one and a half
arms lengths away
and this is from new
york state omh the
safe and supportive
stance right so if you're
right-handed you're
you're facing the
patient with your safest
shoulder side your
left hand you're keeping
that distance that
that one and a half
at least or more
distance than the patient
your front foot at
12, your back foot at
10 or 2, and you're
blading, which means
you're presenting
your narrowest profile
to the patient, knee
slightly bent, hands
above the belt line.
And verbally, you're
calm, you're reassuring,
you're referring to
patients by surname,
you're explaining
everything you're doing
you're constantly
clarifying and
talking that
talking and feeling
are acceptable
acting violent isn't
acknowledge the
patient's ability to harm
others establish
your position as this
wouldn't be acceptable
and we'll have to
we'll act to prevent
harm but don't make
it sound like a
threat, state it as a
matter of fact and
always balance with a
statement. You'll do
what you can to help.
So in summary, we
spoke about the
suicidal patient and
the violent patient.
Know the risk factors for
each, the
suicidal patient
and the dangerous
behavior, aggressive
patient. And knowing
these risk factors,
including the risk
factors for violence
can help save lives so
risk assessment is a
skill that must be
learned and practiced
the psychiatrist cannot
predict we're really
very lousy predictors
especially of
violence or suicide
unless it's in the next
few minutes but
psychiatrists cannot We can't
predict suicide, but
we can utilize risk
and protective factors
to help prevent
dangerous behavior of
violence and suicide.
Note that psychiatric
patients have the
right to confidentiality,
and they can make
their own health care
decisions, including
right to refuse
medication. But in terms of
confidentiality, there
are some exceptions.
There's the
emergency exception
to prevent further harm.
And there's the
exception if there's an
identified victim
from the Tarasov case.
And then getting
back to our original
lecture in this
series, psychiatric
patients are assumed to
have capacity to make
decisions until
proven otherwise.
through the court
system and due process.
And that
concludes suicide
and the violent patient.